Small twist on a standard greeting
and direct enough to show interest but indirect enough
not to be condescending and misogynistic.
Acknowledgement of your non-use of cat-calls or rude observations of my body to get my attention.
Witty response to demonstrate personality independent of a relationship to a man.
Response demonstrating an attitude of appreciation for a partner with independent activity.
Pause of silence to decide whether or not to engage in conversation further with you while maintaining eye contact
to demonstrate confidence and non-intimidation.
Sustained eye contact during silence to show that I, as a politically correct man of the 21st century,
I'm ok with letting a woman make her own choices for herself.
Permission to proceed via witty quip.
Hearty laugh to demonstrate that I understand your wit.
Bartender!
Ordering of a gender-neutral alcoholic drink and pausing briefly to see if the lady would have me order for her, or if she would rather
Drink order for myself, please Bartender
Delivery of drinks with overbearing compliment to the lady.
And a panicked compliment to the gentleman masking sexism with question of my sexuality.
Awkward exit.
(Clink!)
Mm, inquiries about your current state of being with just enough upward inflexion
to communicate genuine interest, as opposed to filler conversation while imagining you naked.
Body language opening to positively reinforce your genuine engagement.
Comment on a minor detail of your response to demonstrate active listening.
Rewarding your vulnerability by initiating a physical relationship by touching your elbow.
Hah, self deprecating joke to demonstrate that I don't take myself too seriously.
[Both]: Hearty laugh.
Handing of my business card to shatter the lipstick on napkin stereotype.
Taking of the business card and handing back my business card because you can call me first too if you want to.  It's 2015.
Politically correct.
Ah, politically correct.
Hearty laugh.
Laugh that's not quite as hearty.
Hm?